[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we're taking a deep dive
into the case of Justin Ross Harris the
father convicted of intentionally
leaving his 22 month old son in a
blistering hot car near Atlanta Georgia
on purpose Harris's murder conviction
was overturned and now we know we he
will not have to go through a trial
again let's get you caught up to speed
on this case so in the summer of 2014
Cooper Harris died in his car seat in
the back of his father's SUV while his
dad went to work in 2016 a jury found
Justin Ross Harris guilty of
intentionally leaving his son to die
Georgia's Supreme Court heard Arguments
for appeal and overturned Harris's
murder conviction in 2022 and nearly a
year after that decision came down the
Cobb County district attorney announced
that it will not retry this case now
Harris left Cooper in the car while he
went to work at the Home Depot corporate
office police say Cooper likely died
around noon and that afternoon Harris
drives around two miles before realizing
that his son is in the backseat he then
pulls over at a shopping center and
bystanders call 9-1-1 Harris was
arrested and charged with murder that
very night search warrants claimed that
Harris searched for hot car deaths
online the defense argued he clicked on
a trending video about dogs dying in hot
cars it's been also revealed that Harris
was sexting with at least six women on
the day that Cooper died one of his
exchanges was with a 16 year old so he
was also charged with sex crimes the
court moved from moved the trial from
the Atlanta area to Coastal Georgia and
a jury found Harris guilty on all counts
now this case had the Metro Atlanta area
in its grip for months Ross Cavett was a
reporter in Cobb County who had
witnessed every part of this case
actually had a chance to speak with him
on Friday and get his thoughts on the
DA's latest decision
this was an interesting case to cover
for for me as a reporter uh because I
was out there the shopping center from
the minute it happened all the way
through the end of the trial
um so you know it was an interesting
Journey the District Attorney's decision
not to retry this case I understand
because much of what they used to get to
the jury where they were has been taken
away by the Supreme Court so I
understand the decision I also
understand the emotions involving that
I'm good friends with one of the former
prosecutors in that case who I know he
is upset about it so I really I see both
sides I will say this on a personal note
there's nothing that trial that whole
experience is nothing I would want to go
through again this was
difficult case to try for a variety of
reasons uh you you had a lot of expert
testimony we tried this hundreds of
miles away it was expensive time
consuming and it took an emotional toll
as well and I think if you put all that
together looking at what they had to to
take to court looking at the cost the
time
um you know that that's probably why
that decision was
all right joining me now our former
trial Attorney Terry Austin and special
guest criminal defense attorney Mike
corobanix Michael start with you welcome
to the program you're also a former
prosecutor so what do you think of this
decision not to try Harris again
well I think it's part of the
responsibility as a prosecutor trials
are not made for people to win or lose
we have an ethical obligation whether
you're a prosecutor or a defense
attorney to make sure the evidence you
produce is relevant it's got credibility
and things of that nature I think this
was a good move by the prosecution
because the Supreme Court said
regardless of whether you agree or don't
agree with it this evidence wasn't
admissible and they also too got a
conviction on other parts of the case so
he is doing prison time so I think it
does show the prosecutor's credibility
whether you agree with it or not is
irrelevant because when you're in court
the standard is different it's not what
you think it's what the jury believes
beyond the Reasonable Doubt and the way
and the wit this doesn't have to be also
credible right it's got to be things
that come in but but Terry you were
convinced there was enough evidence to
retry the case what's stood out to you
well I understand the decision but I
definitely think there's enough there
two things first that timeline and then
also Those computer searches the
timeline was when he he dropped himself
off at work he left his child in the car
then he goes to lunch with someone else
in another car why is he in another car
he probably usually goes in his own car
so I think that was some thing that they
should have questioned then when it
happened when he realized he said he
thought wow this his child was in the
car he pulls over but his affect they
said was really odd so I think that
timeline is really interesting and those
Google searches you can't be searching
hot deaths and cars and also you know he
apparently was searching other things
about you know prison so I think they
have something on him well as Mike said
Harris was also convicted on charges
related to his sexual activities and the
District Attorney's office said in a
statement quote Justin Ross Harris
stands convicted of the remaining counts
of the indictment including criminal
attempt to commit sexual exploitation of
children and dissemination of harmful
material to minors barring a decision
from the State Board of Pardons and
paroles he will continue to serve his
sentence of 12 Years on those counts as
ordered by the trial court we're going
to take a quick break but still had a
long crime daily our coverage of the
reversal of Justin Rossa Harris's murder
conviction continues we're taking you
inside the Georgia supreme court hearing
as the justices heard Arguments for and
against Harris's guilt
foreign
Justin Roth's Terrace
and his actions in a certain light that
took jurors on that trip uh down motive
Lane to show them why he may have done
what he did and how to get to amal's
murder charge
that was former Atlanta area reporter
Ross Cavett talking about the case of
Justin Ross Harris the ones convicted
child killer who had this murder part of
his verdict overturned by the state
supreme court Harris's case captivated
people all over the country as words
spread about his infidelities and
Liaisons with multiple women in fact at
one point he even told a woman he was
sexting with that he would leave his
wife if it wasn't for his almost
two-year-old two-year-old son Cooper and
he would later leave Cooper inside his
SUV while he went to work finding him
dead hours later despite objections from
the defense that inclusion of the
extramarital sex and messaging was too
prejudicial and irrelevant to the case
it was allowed in the prosecution held
that Harris wanted to have a child-free
life so he killed his son Cooper died in
2014 and Harris was convicted in 2016
but in January of 2022 the Georgia
Supreme Court hurt arguments on why
Harris's conviction should be overturned
the answer is yes viewing the evidence
as reasonable jurors would view it there
is a high probability that the sexting
messaging evidence did not contribute to
the murder verdict if it was erroneously
entered in but that is one of the
problems it's not just that he's having
Affairs or that you section people or uh
these things like that but it is the
graphic nature how inflammatory that is
to a jury when they're back there
reading it and it's not just you know
you had 10 testifying Witnesses that's
not just 10 acts because each one of
those Witnesses he had graphic
conversations with on numerous occasions
the the state was allowed to present the
um the transcripts of the messaging with
the photos that were exchanged it was
photos of men and women being exchanged
um explicit sexual photos and just some
really raw graphic language and it just
kept kept piling on
Mike the Supreme Court said that the
trial judge shouldn't have allowed or
omitted that evidence of the defendant's
extramarital Pursuits can you explain
the rationale for that
well I think what they were concerned
about was that and I think this comes on
more and more now that we're in a Time
Of Our Lives where people text
everything quick is that you know quick
responses is that many people talk about
many things but it doesn't necessarily
mean without something more to support
just the text that that's the activity
they went through although it's tough
for me to really understand this because
it seems like there is a connection
between these text messages and a motive
as to why he wanted to kill his son it
seems like they thought it was really
prejudicial it was going to inflame the
passions of the jury instead of really
you know hitting on the evidence that he
wanted to kill his son I mean Terry the
Supreme Court decision wasn't unanimous
what do you think I mean did they come
to the right to right conclusion you
know this is one of those cases where I
think it's about 50 50. I understand the
Supreme Court's decision but it wasn't
unanimous it was six three and I think
those descenders were trying to say look
it does have something to do with motive
you should be able to let some of this
information in but there's a line where
you have to draw perhaps you shouldn't
show pictures of body parts but you can
show to you know demonstrate this
timeline to demonstrate what was on his
mind at the time that this happened so I
do think that some of that should have
gotten in it reminds me actually of the
Alec Murdock case because frankly those
financial crimes that was a big issue
the judge let it in and apparently you
know we think it'll be upheld we don't
know but it could be reversed on that
same ground well the end of the day is
he is going to remain in prison on those
remaining counts but he will not be
retried on the murder so this is a quite
an endnote to the Justin Ross Harris
case